oh [ __ ] I can't what is this ah double
penises hey how's it going my name is so
a couple days ago I asked for enemy
suggestions and I'd say 9 out of 10 of
the [ __ ] comments suggested boku no
pico so I looked up what it was and yeah
that no that's real funny
you wanted me to watch boku no pico I'll
watch we'll watch it together so here we
go
pretty standard anime so far cute girl
she's happy what's the problem so
they're on a date eating ice cream
that's cute
he does not look happy about that ice
cream being eaten there you go oh no oh
God I've seen enough hentai to know
where this is going I mean no mom mom
please I don't watch please mom okay
it's a little kinky I get it hey kinky
stuff happens I'm sure this is nothing
weird so much sucking ice cream out of a
sweater I've done that ok time wait wait
what is that
what is that what was that that must
have been a fish there must have been an
octopus oh it's a tiny penis okay what
how oh [ __ ] we have the same reaction
I sure hope that's a banana from the ice
cream okay it's not Jesus Christ man
calm down don't lick the arm I know this
too much action right now this is fine
hey do what you want to do in life but I
don't you shouldn't have to watch this
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you know they
they obviously love each other and
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong this is this is love Oh
God
no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a
girl it's a guy no it's a boy okay I
can't oh [ __ ] I can't what is this ah
double penises am i watching child porn
for YouTube is just where we are right
now cuz it looks like it I can't I'm I
am out of cans oh [ __ ] they're
sixty-nining that's okay
[Music]
it's licking his [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass no this is there look at that look
how old he is he's like 12 how is this
okay this is episode 2 is child porn
all right great great great great I'm
going I'm the police is gonna get me now
that's great all right
how do I delete my history forever okay
episode three is that a boy or a girl
no no there are sword fighting they are
sir fighting
it's I I'm speechless
they're triple start fighting now their
trip their trip of course triple sword
fight
of course what why wouldn't they up
smack Oh finger a little bit of the
button at the budget oh why not why not
do that I don't owe the triple their
trip are they triple fingering there but
I don't I can't
you just don't put three bananas in a
smoothie everyone knows that everyone
everyone knows it's it's it's the number
one it's the number one rule it's the
number one rule of YouTube you don't put
triple banana and the smoothie of course
she's [ __ ] her in the mouth he's
[ __ ] him in them oh that's a lot of
ice cream that's a lot not a lot of ice
cream holy [ __ ] that is a lot of action
I don't I I don't know are they gonna
they're all gonna oh they're shooting
fireworks they shot they thought they
shot they shot fire think they saw it
fireworks
they shot if they saw fireworks everyone
what an ending what an epic ending to
BOGO no [ __ ] Pecos they shot [ __ ]
fireworks all at the same time and the
Digi no starlet of the city
did you know Pico the greatest anime
since 1969 yes yes
please please no please let's not
exclusive snot do that my stomach hurts
I'm there's been a stressful mess but I
made it through three episodes of boku
[ __ ] no pico okay well I'm just
gonna go and bathe in Bleach I'll hope
you enjoyed this video if you did leave
a like and I'll see you in the next
episode what is happening
always putting up a jar boku no pico
boku no pico more like a boku yes pico
am i right ladies
no okay